continuing this theme the French have
given us so many great things and wine
beautiful art clothes cuisine and here
is one of the greatest French exports
ladies and gentlemen Catherine Deneuve
to bring new fashion up-to-date the
nominees for the best achievement in
custom design this year are Bram
Stoker's Dracula Iacocca and shaded
approach in innate here
Oh what hands Jenny Beavan and John
bride and Malcolm X Ruth Carter toys
other Wolski and the Oscar goes to I
equal Chaka Khan Chaka Dracula
thank you so much for members Academy
and the Columbia Pictures and still I'm
sorry I have a note I need a note to
give the spinach from my heart thank you
to Francis Ford Coppola for this great
chance for his remarkable College he is
in taking the risk to trust in my work
thank you to all my fellow collaborators
and contrast friends who have helped
supported me a lot and finally thank you
- Oscar designed by Cedric Gibbons the
most beautiful designed man in this
planet thank you very much